- Also erzähl mal: Wie geht's denn
mit deiner Brücke voran?
- Du meinst die Brücke
für den Wettbewerb?
- Ja, genau.
- Ich habe ziemlich viel zu tun, trotzdem
bin ich schon weitergekommen.
- Und bist du zufrieden?
- Hm, noch nicht ganz.
Aber ich hatte die Idee, Solarzellen an
die Seiten zu montieren.
Die können die Lampen auf der Brücke
dann mit Strom versorgen.
Das fanden ein paar andere gut und
machen jetzt mit.
- Cool!
- Ich finde alternative Energien sowieso am
interessantesten, auch in der Architektur …
Man kann auch an Gebäuden viel
Energie sparen. Das ist so spannend!
- Ja, ich hab' neulich einen Artikel über
intelligente Häuser gelesen.
- So, zwei Mal die Tagessuppe.
Bitte schön. Guten Appetit.
- Danke.
- Hallo, Tarek.
- Na, hallo!
- Ist Max gar nicht hier?
- Nein, der hat heute frei.
Möchtest du was essen?
- Ähm, gleich.
Lisa, hallo!
- Hallo, Yara. Wie geht's?
- Gut. Ähm, ich will auch gar nicht
lange stören,
aber wenn ich dich jetzt gerade sehe ...
- Was gibt's denn?
- Ähm, ich will für morgen einen kleinen
Flohmarkt für Flüchtlinge organisieren.
- Ähm, gebrauchte Sachen, Fahrräder,
Klamotten …
Wenn ihr irgendwas habt, was ihr nicht
mehr braucht, dann bringt's gerne vorbei.
- Ja, das ist 'ne super Idee. Ich sag'
gleich meinen Schülern Bescheid
und du deinen Eltern!
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist echt sehr nett, vielen Dank!
- Entschuldigung, Yara.
- Selma.
- Selma? Nicos Selma?
Freut mich!
Dann sehen wir uns morgen!
- Bis morgen.
- Bis dann.
- Also Selma … Du und Nico:
Was ist denn da los?